ein flickenteppich an corona regeln
sachsen-anhalt erlaubt jetzt einwohnern
in fünfergruppen rauszugehen und auch
die großen läden dürfen öffnen
eine debatte in 90 wohnzimmern beim
ersten online parteitag der grünen
fordert die parteispitze ein
milliardenschweres konjunkturprogramm
und eine attacke mit konsequenzen nach
dem angriff auf ein kamerateam der zdf-
heute-show ermittelt der staatsschutz
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem samstag schön dass sie dabei sind
in der korona krise wächst der druck auf
bund und länder wieder mehr freiheiten
zu lassen nicht nur wirtschaftsverbände
verlangen klare perspektiven
auch eltern künstler und vereine wollen
wissen worauf sie sich einstellen müssen
kanzlerin und ministerpräsidenten wollen
am mittwoch beraten
doch schon heute brechen wieder erste
bundesländer vor sachsen anhalt zum
beispiel david sauer hat mehr ein
bisschen normalität kehrt zurück nach
sachsen anhalt ab montag dürfen dann
fünf statt bislang zwei menschen
zusammen sein
auch wenn sie nicht in einem haushalt
leben auch sport zu fünft im freien
erlaubt die landesregierung unter
auflagen mit dem zusatz dass wir hier
einen erheblichen schritt nach vorne
gehen und auch korrektur fähig bleiben
müssen aber wir glauben dass
verantworten zu können ein grund das
land hat sehr wenige corona fälle
gestern wurden nur sieben neuinfektionen
gemeldet
besucher in alten und pflegeheimen
erlaubt sachsen anhalt ab dem 11
eine person für eine stunde pro tag und
auch andernorts wird gelockert im
saarland dürfen ab montag alle geschäfte
öffnen egal wie groß bedingung nur ein
kunde pro 20 quadratmeter deutschland
ein mosaik aus einzeln
hier ist mittlerweile so einen
lockerungs wettlauf entstanden oder kann
dazu führen dass die disziplinen in der
bevölkerung zusammenbricht vor allem die
wirtschaft drängt auf zügiges wieder
hochfahren
dass es nicht zu verkraften denn das
noch lange so anhält dann wird eine
pleitewelle kommt die wir noch nie
hatten und pleitewelle heißt
arbeitslosigkeit der mittelstand braucht
planungssicherheit mit diesen zwei
wochen entscheidungen können wir nicht
leben
am 6 mai berät die bundeskanzlerin
erneut mit den ministerpräsidenten der
länder
sie werden das maß finden müssen
zwischen lockern und beschränken
die grünen verlangen mehr klarheit von
der bundesregierung nach welchen
kriterien die korona maßnahmen gelockert
oder verschärft werden
auch sie wollen der wirtschaft helfen
allerdings nur unter bedingungen
die firmen müssten die staatshilfen
nutzen um sich klima und
umweltfreundlich auszurichten
alles themen heute auf einem parteitag
wie es ihnen so noch nie gab
patrick wiedemeyer berichtet modern
innovativ digital so wollen sie sich
präsentieren die grünen seien die ersten
die ein demokratisches experiment wagen
einen digitalen parteitag nur der
parteivorstand ist anwesend in berlin
alle anderen redner werden von zuhause
zugeschaltet in zeiten der krise wo die
regierung im mittelpunkt steht endlich
mal wieder wahrgenommen werden so das
ziel
gerade in einer zeit wo arbeitslosigkeit
druck angst vor krankheit das nicht
sehen von angehörigen der soziale stress
immer größer wird muss politik sich
erklären herbigs co-vorsitzende baerbock
fordert eine vorsichtige und
schrittweise öffnung von pflegeheim und
kitas leben sei mehr als nur zu
überleben
wir müssen genau dort in diesen
bereichen wo die grundrechts
einschränkungen so hart zuschlagen alles
dafür tun dass wir endlich zu den
voraussetzungen kommen dass schutz
bedingung dass schutzausrüstung wirklich
auch für milderung sorgen kann
zudem dürfe der akute zustand nicht zu
einer grossen wirtschaftskrise werden
ein konjunkturprogramm im umfang von 100
milliarden euro soll aufgelegt werden
dass auch der umwelt und dem klimaschutz
nütze
kultur und aufbauprogramme die jetzt
kommen müssen grün imprägniert sein
die klimakrise ist viel schwieriger zu
bewältigen als crooner denn die
klimakrise kann man nicht mehr gehen mit
uns grünen werden kurze lieferwege
regionale nachhaltige produkte und
lebendige innenstadt die gewinner der
krise sein und eben nicht die riesen
unternehmen wie amazon und co
um das programm zu finanzieren wollen
die grünen unter anderem wohlhabende
stärker zur kasse bitten
es war ein parteitag ohne applaus ohne
das gespräch zwischendurch aber auch mit
vielen technischen problemen so ist dies
wohl kein modell für die zukunft
noch ist unbekannt wer gestern ein team
der heute show in berlin brutal
attackiert hat und warum
der staatsschutz ermittelt die sechs
festgenommenen wurden inzwischen wieder
freigelassen
das team der zdf satiresendung hatte am
rande einer demo gegen die korona
vorschriften gedreht später prügelten
vermummte auf die kollegen ein und
verletzten vier von ihm aus berlin
stefan ihr eigen nennt berlins
polizeipräsident in den angriff auf das
kamerateam der heute-show völlig
unvermittelt sehr eine gruppe von 20 bis
25 vermummten auf die sieben
fernsehmacher um satiriker abdel karim
losgegangen habe getreten und geschlagen
vier menschen wurden zum teil erheblich
verletzt berlins innensenator verurteilt
den angriff
ich wünsche den mitarbeiterinnen
mitarbeitern das zdf gute genesung und
muss ausdrücklich sagen aus welcher
motivation auch immer das geschehen ist
rechts links oder rechts motivation noch
immer solche angriffe gegen
medienvertreter gehen gar nicht
das fernsehteam hatte zuvor auf einer
inzwischen regelmäßige zusammenkunft von
kritikern der korona beschränkungen
gedreht auf der sich sehr
unterschiedliche strömungen treffen und
war auf dem rückweg zu den autos direkt
nach dem angriff nahm die polizei zwei
frauen und vier männer fest sie sind
zwischen 24 und 31 jahre alt über ihre
motive geben die ermittler noch keine
auskunft
der vorsitzende des deutschen
journalistenverbandes beklagt dass
gewalt gegen die presse zunimmt
grundsätzlich pressefreiheit ist wichtig
und egal welcher mission kolleginnen und
kollegen unterwegs sind darf man sie
nicht angreifen das erleben wir bei
demonstrationen in letzter zeit immer
häufiger dass journalistinnen und
journalisten gewalttätig angegriffen
werden ja zum teil sogar verletzt werden
und das muss aufhören
inzwischen sind die tatverdächtigen
wieder entlassen aber wegen des
verdachts des besonders schweren
landfriedensbruchs hat der polizeiliche
staatsschutz die ermittlungen übernommen
in berlin gab es noch weitere festnahmen
weil doch einige gegen das aktuelle
demonstrationsverbot verstießen im
kreuzberg versammelten sich rund 1000
menschen zu einer unerlaubten
maikundgebung es kam zu rangeleien mit
der polizei rund 20 beamte wurden
verletzt mehr als 200 personen wurden
vorübergehend festgenommen
auch in hamburg gab es
auseinandersetzungen zwischen
demonstranten und der polizei
trotz des verbots hatten linke gruppen
zu spontanen aktionen aufgerufen
schauen wir auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen in deutschland nach angaben der
johns hopkins universität sind stand 18
30 insgesamt mehr als 100 64.000 corona
infizierte durch tests bestätigt davon
geld mehr als 129 1000 betroffene als
genesen 6736 menschen sind in verbindung
mit dem virus gestorben 1307
neuinfektionen gibt es seit gestern auch
für arztpraxen hat die korona pandemie
massive folgen nicht nur wegen der hohen
infektionsgefahr für ärzte und ihre
mitarbeiter aus angst vor ansteckung
bleiben viele patienten weg christine
eder hat mehr leere wartezimmer auch
hier in der landarztpraxis rintelmann im
niedersächsischen bad nenndorf
trotz aller vorkehrungen gegen die
infektion nur wenige trauen sich in die
praxis aus angst dass der arzt die stadt
zu heilen das krank machende virus
überträgt
jetzt april war ein rückgang von über 50
prozent festzustellen wo hingegen die
telefonanruf hatte ich so roland prozent
gestiegen sind bundesweit klagen haus
und fachärzte über finanzielle einbußen
die kaum aufzufangen sein dazu die sorge
um die patienten die auch dringende
untersuchungen nicht waren ihnen zum
beispiel onkologen haben kürzlich alarm
gegeben dass sie sagen ganz viele
patienten kommen nicht mehr zu den krebs
vorsorge und insofern ist die große
gefahr dass wir viele krebserkrankungen
gerade im frühen stadium nicht mehr
erkennen und das sind tatsächlich der
potenziell lebensgefährliche
erkrankungen die eigentlich vermeidbar
werden ferndiagnose für die die sonst
fernbleiben würden wie der
allgemeinmediziner thomas stiller
erproben jetzt tausende ärzte erstmals
den umgang mit der technik
jede vierte praxis bietet bereits video
behandlungen an die digitale
sprechstunde aber kein allheilmittel
video sprechstunden an sich ist nicht
der goldstandard der goldstandard ist
dass ich mit allen fünf sinnen die
patienten sozusagen untersuchen kann
und ich muss auch sagen die nachfrage
ist eigentlich möchten sie lieber hier
sein und sie benutzen das tatsächlich
nur als notnagel ein notnagel ein
zuverdienst auch für die ärzte die
online behandlung abrechnen können sie
hoffen aber dass ihre patienten
möglichst bald auch wieder persönlich
kommen große sorge herrscht auf einem
kreuzfahrtschiff in cuxhaven dort wurde
ein crewmitglied positiv auf corona
getestet an bord befinden sich keine
gäste mehr sondern knapp 2900
besatzungsmitglieder von mehreren
schiffen 15 personen meldeten sich mit
grippeähnlichen symptomen da derzeit
keine kreuzfahrten möglich sind sollten
die mitarbeiter in ihre heimatländer
gebracht werden fabian köhler ist für
uns vor ort wie ist die situation auf
dem schiff fabian na ja die gute
nachricht bis hierhin soweit es wurden
weitere tests durchgeführt und bislang
gibt es keinen weiteren positiven fall
an bord man hat sich dazu entschlossen
dass alle 2899 crew mitglieder die sich
an bord befinden getestet werden sollen
dazu gehen spezialisten des
gesundheitsamtes heute oder
spätestens morgen an bord dann wird das
schiff auslaufen und in der deutschen
bucht vor anker gehen
auch um dort frisch was er aufzunehmen
und dann werden weitere tests erfolgen
die ergebnisse folgen dann
voraussichtlich in der nächsten woche
die frage die sich nun alle stellen ist
wie konnte das corona virus an bord
kommen
letztmalig hatte das schiff am 17 april
in teneriffa vor anker gelegen hat dort
andere crew mitglieder der gesamten
flotte aufgenommen und ist dann hier
nach cuxhaven gefahren
das problem ist sicherlich für die
menschen die sich jetzt an bord befinden
die hatten hier das land schon vor augen
und die busse standen schon bereit und
wären dann in ihre heimatländer verteilt
worden
und jetzt müssen sie wieder auf sie
gehen und dort auf den rücktransport
warten also emotional ist das sicherlich
keine einfache situation für die
menschen an bord dankeschön für diese
informationen aus cuxhaven fabian köhler
war dass die us arzneimittelbehörde hat
per ausnahmegenehmigung ein medikament
zugelassen das kogit 19 patienten helfen
soll der wirkstoffe rennen der sie wir
gilt schon länger als vielversprechend
kürzlich hat eine klinische studie
ergeben dass patienten die das
medikament erhielten schneller gesund
wurden die zahl der todesfälle blieb
aber in etwa gleich
am heftigsten hat das corona virus in
den usa die stadt new york getroffen
in der achteinhalb millionen metropole
haben sich bislang 175.000 menschen
infiziert das sind mehr als in ganz
deutschland und new york hat fast
dreimal soviel corona tote 18.000
inzwischen sinkt die zahl der
neuinfektionen dort das schlimmste
scheint erstmal überwunden
johannes hano berichtet als die joses
komforth das krankenhaus schiff der
us-marine vom p in new york city ablegt
liegt hoffnungen der luft hoffnung dass
die stadt das schlimmste zumindest für
den moment hinter sich hat auch wenn die
ausgangs beschränkungen noch bis zum 15
mai in kraft bleiben
immer mehr patienten werden entlassen
neuen weisungen gehen zurück und auch
die zahl der toten von etwa 800 auf
knapp 300 pro tag
doch wie schlimm die katastrophe new
york getroffen hat wird immer deutlicher
in brooklyn muss ende der woche die
polizei anrücken weil vor einem
beerdigungsunternehmen den angemieteten
lastern dutzende leichen verwesen
anwohner hatten sich über den geruch
beschwert das gesundheitssystem ist
nicht in der lage der vielen toten herr
zu werden
zwei drittel der opfer stammen aus der
black and braun community obwohl die nur
30 prozent der gesamtbevölkerung
ausmacht hunderttausende sind arbeitslos
haben ihre krankenversicherung verloren
oder sind auf lebensmittelspenden
angewiesen ein hilferuf des gründers wir
könnten finanzielle unterstützung für
die lebensmittel tafeln gut gebrauchen
unser haushalt ist bei allem was
passiert auch unter druck wir haben das
geld nicht um zu tun was getan werden
muss wir wären dankbar für spenden für
die tafel auch wenn sich die lage
langsam bessert das virus fördert auf
brutale art und weise die enormen
sozialen und politischen probleme ans
tageslicht probleme die viel zu lange
ignoriert worden sind medizinisch
scheint new york die lage in den griff
zu bekommen die gesellschaftlichen
konflikte aber die das virus offenbart
hat werden new york noch lange
beschäftigen
in spanien dem land mit den europaweit
schärfsten ausgesperrten gibt es weitere
vorsichtige lockerungen erstmals seit
sieben wochen dürfen die menschen wieder
draußen spazieren gehen oder sport
machen allerdings jede altersgruppe nur
zu bestimmten zeiten
es ist die erste von vier phasen mit der
bis ende juni wieder mehr normalität
erreicht werden soll
spanien ist mit mehr als 24.000 corona
toten eines der am schlimmsten
betroffenen länder
jedes land hat seine eigenen corona
schutzmaßnahmen welche sind das und wann
sie wieder aufgehoben werden eine kurze
übersicht haben wir auf der zdf heute
app für sie zusammengestellt ganz
vorsichtig nähert sich deutschland einem
halbwegs normalen leben und dazu gehört
für viele natürlich auch der
fußball-bundesliga will wieder loslegen
mit geisterspielen und vielen tests
damit kein infizierter spieler andere
ansteckt beim ersten fc köln gibt es
jetzt ergebnisse zwei spiele und ein
betreuer sind positiv getestet was das
für den neustart bedeutet erklärt
andreas kürten die drei positiv auf
corona getesteten das erste fc köln
haben sich umgehend in quarantäne
begeben bisher ohne krankheitssymptome
nach beratungen der
vereinsverantwortlichen mit dem kölner
gesundheitsamt wird der trainingsbetrieb
mit dem bisherigen hygiene konzept
weiter gehen
man ist dann zu bewertungen gekommen
dass dieses konzept eben tragfähig ist
und das bedeutet dass all die spieler
die negativ getestet worden sind eben
nicht zu kontakt fonds und 1 deklariert
worden sind und deshalb am spielbetrieb
teilnehmen können und das ist eine gute
nachricht seit donnerstag wird von den
bundesliga vereinen mit blick auf eine
fortsetzung der saison umfangreich
getestet bei der dfl bewertet man die
ergebnisse aus köln nicht als rückschlag
sondern sieht sich in den maßnahmen
bestätigt würden wir davon ausgehen dass
sowieso keiner positiv ist bräuchten wir
gar nicht zu testen
es werden zwei tests vorm auftakt des
mannschaftstrainings gemacht um sicher
zu stellen soweit das eben geht das im
mannschaftstraining keine ansteckenden
personen sind kritiker aber verweisen
auf gesundheitliche risiken und die
vorbildfunktion des fußballs wenn also
hier spieler infiziert sind dann sollte
die gesamte mannschaft in quarantäne war
so würden wir es ja auch handhaben in
jedem betrieb und so würden wir es auch
vom bürger erwarten wir können hier
nicht für die fußballer einer ausnahme
machen das versteht der bürger nicht und
das gefährdet auch die spieler bei der
dfl hofft man auf eine fortsetzung der
saison mitte mai mit sogenannten
geisterspielen dazu braucht es die
zustimmung von bundesregierung und
ländern
vielleicht wird der kommende mittwoch
klarheit bringen ob die hoffnungen
berechtigt sind
mehr zum thema sehen sie morgen in der
zdf sportreportage um 17 uhr 10
mit der aussicht auf lockerungen haben
wir begonnen und so wollen wir auch
enden denn ab montag ist ja wieder etwas
mehr erlaubt in einem teil der
bundesländer dürfen kosmetikstudios
wieder öffnen ebenso wie nagel und
massagestudios und von vielen besonders
sehnsüchtig erwartet bundesweit machen
friseure wieder auf
sebahat details sechs wochen ohne
haarschnitt gehen zu ende für manchen
wird es auch langsam zeit
meine nichte haben mir die haare
geschnitten und jetzt sehe ich so ein
bisschen aus wie fred feuerstein
das ist ein corona haarschnitt ja schön
für die friseure dass sie wieder
aufmachen können und wieder geld
verdienen können ja ich brauche den
termin aber ich werde bestimmt auch noch
keinen kriegen damit am montag ihr laden
in schwerin wieder läuft sorgte und
christin dafür dass alles sicher ist
anderthalb meter abstand zur
empfangstheke desinfektionsmittel und
mund nasen schutz für alle 3000 euro
haben die beiden inhaberinnen in ihre
schutzmaßnahmen investiert und das sind
ab montag die regeln masken für
friseurinnen und kunden haare waschen
ist pflicht keine gesichts narren
dienstleistungen wie rasieren oder
wimpern färben und die kontaktdaten der
kunden sind zu dokumentieren
mögliche infektionskette können so
nachverfolgt werden
außerdem dürfen keine getränke mehr
angeboten werden zeitschriften sind tabu
wartebereiche ebenso der salon
goldkinder ist für die nächsten zwei
wochen fast ausgebucht möchte frisch auf
den kopf sein also werden sehr fitte tun
haben gott sei dank die preise
allerdings werden steigen mit ein bis
zwei euro pro haarschnitt müssen die
kunden wohl rechnen
schaue aber auch viel sonnenschein
verspricht der sonntag die details dazu
hat gleich osten terry für sie die
neuesten nachrichten hat dann christian
sievers im heute journal um viertel vor
elf machen sie sich noch einen schönen
samstagabend danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit und bis morgen wenn sie
mögen
[Musik]
ein stammte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter von der nordsee her erreicht uns
kühlere luft und dementsprechend bilden
sich dann über dem nordosten
deutschlands dann schauer ansonsten
lockert es auf und es wird im südwesten
etwas wärmer
schauen wir auf die nacht im osten
deutschlands gibt es noch regen der
zieht allmählich ab und auch an den
alpen regnet es bis auf 1000 meter
schneit es herunter ansonsten klart es
teilweise auf und die temperaturen
sinken vor allem wo die wolken im westen
fehlen bis auf null grad zum beispiel
richtung eifel ein grad an den alpen
sonst an den küsten um die 7 grad sowie
an der neiße morgen im tagesverlauf also
im nordosten schauer die allmählich
richtung erzgebirge ziehen an den küsten
lockert es wieder auf genauso wie im
westen scheint die sonne auch ganz im
süden gibt es einige schauer
die höchsten temperaturen 19 grad im
südwesten entlang des rheins meist 17
bis 18 ansonsten 12 bis 13
teils 16 grad im osten deutschlands die
kommenden tage am montag bekommen wir
neue schauer aus dem südwesten bei 11
bis 22 grad und ab dienstag wird es
allmählich trockener und mittwoch fällt
dann kein tropfen mehr damit ein schöner
abend